today we're looking at another  ridiculous checkmate in one puzzle  in this position it is black's turn to  move and there's actually checkmate in  one  against the white king if you can even  find it now at first glance this might  seem  impossible to solve but the thing to do  is to look at  all of the night squares all of the  knight jumps away from the king  and find which one is undefended is this  checkmate  no defended is this checkmate no  is this checkmate no no  uh there's a king in the way no  and then no and that leaves us with our  solution  this is the only knight check square  that is undefended  black plays knight takes b4 with  checkmate  winning the fake puzzle good luck  solving this one at home  as always my name is caleb denvey let me  know in the comments if you like this  short  and i'll see you next time